parler de rimbaud dit pierre michaud
c'est parler de soi même qui sont à mi
chemin entre réalité et fiction pour
elle son livre est à la fois une
biographie intime et un hommage rendu à
arthur rimbaud
enfin bon moi je les mettais la première
fois que je n'ai que je n'ai vu que je
n'ai que je n'ai que je vais plus
d'avoir une reproduction son portrait
que j'ai vu quelques extraits de son
oeuvre et que j'ai vu des morceaux de sa
biographie c'était dans l'almanach
vermot ont soulevé l'anac vernon enfin
peut-être que mon grand-père acheter ça
tous les hommes il y avait en dessous
des en dessous des petites vignettes
humoristiques avait des articles de fond
si on peut dire pouvoir pour
l'alternance et à lire des articles
extrêmement simpliste comme ça et là il
y avait un article sur rango c'était
vraiment la légende de sarrab roncquois
c'était revault un très grand poème qui
s'est tue les parties dans le désert etc
alors comprendre ça qu'on est tout petit
campus on est très provincial comme
c'était très campagne à sa deviens
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire et qu'on veut
qu'on veut égaler un jour
évidemment qu'on et gagnent jamais
écrire un livre sur rimbaud en plus
l'année du centenaire alors qu'il y en a
eu tellement décrit sol un beau c'est
presqu'un risque effectivement avoir
fait un livre d'avoir fait paraître
l'année de du centenaire c'est un côté
c'est un côté charognards comme ça enfin
tous les tous les tous les vivants qui
se précipitent sur ce grand cadavre pour
pour ans pour en faire leur beurre
finalement mais après tout il ya de pire
modèle pour les jeunes gens après tout
c'est bien de proposer ce modèle là à
les jeunes c'est un modèle qui n'est ni
d'eau logiquement qu'ils étaient là
prochain
qui est qui et qui est
qui est un grand idéaliste et quelqu'un
qui est finalement n'est pas du tout
comme comme le modèle social dominant de
notre temps donc c'est bien
ses courses sans qu'enfin un texte est
l'une des plus grandes - gérer sortir
est là avec une arme plages de temps sur
le jour en mai mais nuit mes rêves de
son plein du texte sur confrère frédéric
écrit avec rocé site
c'est ce jour-là à corps perdu dans ce
nid dans une aventure d'écriture pendant
un mois ou deux de l'année le résultat
on bricole on cherche on ont fait mûrir
les textes ont fait monter les textes
mais ils sont pas encore là ils sont là
quand on vraiment on dit ça y est je me
mets et je le fais il ya un état de
jubilation qui accompagne l'acte
d'écrire oui vous êtes heureux ça vous
rend heureux d'écrire
oui ça me rend très heureuse c'est une
très grande jubilation maintenance une
angoisse et perdu parce qu'on dit
toujours est ce que demain est ce que ce
que je viens de faire aujourd'hui cette
espèce de l'extrême efforts d'extrême
tension est ce que demain je pourrais
encore le faire